reposition everything got the i made
some russian teas it's perfect
i need the red pen though
i need i need i need some serious
penetrating
let's roll the cameras you guys ready
[Music]
from russia though let's go e4
and let's try another danish game will
we finally have a danish gambit is the
key question here
will we finally have a danish gambit
it's called nikolai the first no we well
and he goes d6 so he plays like a
philidor
kind of a philidor type of move and
you guys might immediately see that
white has
the option of taking on e5 and taking on
d8 that may seem good because you're
depriving black of castling right and
it's a good thing when your opponent
loses counselling rights
the problem with that of course is that
you trade queens while doing so
and trading queens lessens the effect of
losing castling rights and in the name
of playing aggressively
i want to keep the queens on the board
so let's not overthink it
let's play knight f3 transposing to a
philidor
bishop g4 and those of you with a good
knowledge of chess history this is how
philidor against duke of brunswick went
what should white do in this position do
we take now
or is it still premature
so i'm leading you guys on a little bit
tricking you it actually is not
premature this is the opera game
we do take on e5 what has changed
well you guys might say well what do you
mean d takes e5 d takes c5
and we can't take with a knight because
queen takes queen that's just checkmate
but after d-e-d-e we can take their
queen first
and what's changed is that now the e5
pawn uh
is under fire by the knight and black's
only way
to avoid losing a pawn while he loses a
pawn is to take on f3 and that is how
the opera game continued the opera game
is probably the most famous game in
chess history
um it's morphy against duke of brunswick
and count isaward
i'm quite certain that many of you have
seen it it's also in my opinion one of
the most overrated games in chess
history but the fact remains and we went
upon we attacked the bishop and we
threatened f7 he has to drop his bishop
back
whoa that is an early resignation holy
smokes this guy was not happy
um maybe he's watching the stream who
knows
he's trying to sabotage me not
acceptable i demand that he take his
resignation back i do not accept his
resignation
well what to say guys that's
uh we take the we take those i guess now
one sec
obviously after
e4 e5 d4 d6
uh just to illustrate what i was saying
this trades queens and black can no
longer castle
right but it should make intuitive sense
that with the queen's off the board
the king losing castling rights isn't
quite as important because king safety
itself
while still very important and it's very
much possible to
deliver checkmate in the end game to
attack in the end game it's a lot harder
to do so
so black is actually completely fine
here and this king
can find a very nice home on c7 so what
you'll often see in these positions
is c6 followed by king c7 this pawn on
c6
also limits the mobility of white's
knight on c3 so
uh the king can do this sort of
semi-castling by hand which
renders this not very effective so
knight f3 bishop g4
and the best move for black here is to
defend the spawn or to take on d4 bishop
g4 is considered a mistake
and so in this position um
the morphe game continued bishop takes
f3 queen takes f3 and now d takes e5
but now black has violated a key opening
principle he's moved a piece out twice
and taken it for the night he's not
developed at all neither is white but
white does have this queen on f3
and morphy goes bishop c4 that threatens
scholars mate
and after knight f6 came a very famous
move like this move is the hallmark
of the opera game one of the hallmarks
what did morphe play here yeah
a lot of you guys know this by heart and
uh you could sniff out the opera game
while skydiving at 40
000 feet i can certainly recite it
that kind of a condition but queen b3
fourkovich
boom boom black cannot defend both pawns
at the same time
i will not show the full opera game
right now you guys can look it up just
search opera game on google do that
right now if you haven't seen
it and play through it on one of eight
eight gazillion sites that have it
the reason that i think this game is
overrated is because while it's a great
illustration it's a great game it's a
great illustration of certain themes i
show it to be
well i don't teach a lot of beginners
but i think beginners should see it but
it shouldn't be
treated as like the only illustration of
these concepts it's a nice game
it's nothing out you know out of the
you know it's nothing crazy and the
opera was norma so the reason it's
called the opera game
is because it was played during a
production of i think it was puccini's
opera i don't know who's opera
who who wrote norma but uh morphe was in
europe and he was invited by
you know this account and these royal uh
you know these these aristocrats to
attend an opera more if he got bored as
one would
at the opera and so he turned his back
to the opera theater and they started
playing this game
anyways it's a it's a fantastic story
and there's some historical trivia
behind it
um and if you guys want that historical
trivia i can find it let me go back to
full cam
i know you guys like chess history now i
have a great
website that has excellent chess
scholarship let's see what i can find
about it real
right quick okay
the duke of brunswick with whom morphy
first dined on
the 19th of september this is from uh
edward winter chess historian was a
confirmed chess player hardly to be seen
otherwise than at chess
edge uh other historian says that they
were frequent visitors to the duke's box
at the italian opera and even there the
new play chess so
what you guys should understand is that
you know like at ball games the
you know the wealthy people and the
owners have their own box it's the same
thing
uh at the opera um they were frequent
visitors to the duke's box at the
italian opera and even there the duke
play chess
on their first visit in october they
played chess throughout the entire
performance of norma
edge mentions morphy's discomfort when
he was the duke's guest
since he was obliged to sit with us back
to the stage while facing the duke and
counties who are consulted against him
so
he was afraid other people think he's an
[ __ ] for not not even
looking at the opera theater but turning
his back on it and playing chess
um okay so
on november the 2nd they heard the
barber of seville during which more if
he played his most famous game no
actually there seems to be debate upon
about which opera
they were listening to and this chess
historians undertakes an investigation
to find out some people say it's norma
some people say it's the barber of
seville
and he he does this long investigation
and he finds tickets from
that season of the opera and where was
this game played
actually let me see i think it was in
italy i'm not sure
was it in austria where exactly was it
yeah anyways it was in paris wait where
was it
frequent visitors norma was also
performing 9th and 20th of december
it appears that murphy versus the count
of the duke was played either during
aportments of nora but most probably
during the barber of seville
on 4th november 1858 so
edward winter who is my favorite chess
historian he thinks that that that it
actually was played during the barber of
seville
um rossini i think anyways
that's a little bit of chest history for
you let's get back to the speed run
whoops um
now in the game of course our opponent
takes
and knight takes c5 happens and he
shouldn't have resigned
i think he resigned because he thought
this was a fork but after bishop e6
while black is in big trouble you know
he can play
and it's really only a pawn down then
you can chase the knight away and you
can keep developing
any questions about this game one day we
will get a chance to play the danish
i promise you
okay looks like we're all good let's get
the next game underway
and we got another wet against spheros
gg let's go e5
alrighty four
well we got another stab at it d4 and
this time you go c6 so
still our opponents are just not
responding to this particularly well and
c6 is not
good move for many reasons one of which
is it takes away the c6 square from the
knight
um the other is that it just doesn't
defend the pawn i mean so we just take
the pawn oh he can win the pawn back
does anybody can anybody find a move
that forcibly wins the e5 pawn pack
and he finds it actually queen a5 check
uh which is kind of funny but
this forks upon the queen now the issue
with this is of course that he's
using his queen for all of this he's not
developing his pieces
and he's allowing me to develop minds
how should we block this check
what is the best way to block this check
so there's there's
most of you are saying 93 which is
correct some of you are saying there
should be two bishop d2 is very tempting
because it
it's with tempo right it attacks the
queen the problem with bishop d2 is that
he's going to move his queen anyway he's
going to take his pawn so you don't need
to
you don't need to push the queen toward
the pawn and the issue with bishop d2 is
that
that's not where you want your bishop
it's a very passive square so
knight c3 is a better way to defend
against the check
and after queen takes c5
how should we continue yeah also the
knight defends the e4 pawn which is good
knight f3
definitely and now we have two pieces
developed we attack his queen
the development advantage balloons and
again he's really hurt by the fact that
he can't get his night out at all
because both development squares are
are are blocked by pawns
okay so if i were black i would i would
play queen c
well keep goes queen e6 i think his idea
is that he's trying to prevent me from
playing bishop c4
he's gonna uh just take my bishop
but that queen is also really in the way
and
in the name of playing very aggressively
now we're going to sort of violate a
rule now some of you may be thinking
along the lines of playing bishop f4 or
bishop d3 but
when you're ahead in development you can
afford to take certain liberties
that you otherwise couldn't have taken
right we already have both of our nights
developed so we don't actually need to
get obsessed with uh developing all of
our pieces as quickly as possible
and if you take a look at a close look
at this queen you will see that it
it allows us to mount a very quick
attack on the f7 pawn a lot of you guys
are seeing the move thank you jay
forester
the move is knight g5 it sort of
manufactures our own fried liver right
knight g5 attacks the queen
and then we can follow up with bishop c4
so
you know if there's a if there's a good
reason to
make to move the same piece more than
once in the opening
uh this is where we sort of begin to
strategically violate the rules okay
knight g5 queen e5
um there definitely is
i think a temptation to play f4 but
that's a little bit counterproductive
because it
it weakens the king it prevents the
bishop from developing and it allows the
queen
uh to sort of depart its uh to leave the
center which is not a good thing for us
because we can
continue to use the queen to accelerate
the pace of our development so let's
play bishop c4
i hope that makes sense um and i've been
making this kind of refrain several
points throughout the speed
throughout these early games which is
that you want to be very careful about
making moves just because they threaten
one of your opponent's pieces
or just because they create a threat
people often equate
threats with a move being good but you
know that isn't
necessarily the case okay b5 now what
should we take on f7 what well this is
actually not the easiest question
because some of you may be attracted
to knight takes f7 and think well this
gives a fork to the queen and the rook
but if you calculate a little bit
further right knight takes f7
he moves the queen away he moves it to
e7 for example
and if you take the rook um then
what is black going to do and can
somebody explain to me why that is a
little bit messy
because he takes the bishop and then the
knight is trapped and he might get two
pieces for a rook
but as a little bit of an introduction
to calculation when you're calculating a
variation
um when when the variation doesn't work
you don't want to go back to the start
and consider the next candidate move
what you really want to do is you want
to go back to the last moment at which
you had a choice
last moment in which you had a choice
the last moment of which you had a
choice is not knight takes f7 it's
actually knight takes rook
you got to ask yourself well is that
move forced
so if we think about it for a second
after knight f7 queen e7
do we have to take the rook are we in a
hurry
exactly we aren't we can move the bishop
to b3
the knight will still be protected and
then we take the rook
and at most he's going to win that night
probably for a couple of pawns
and uh even then we're going to be up an
exchange and uh you know a bunch of
hunts
so you know the algorithm of calculation
often takes the form of calculating an
entire line and then going back to the
start and looking at the next candidate
move
but instead you want to go back to the
last moment it's sort of iterative
i think it you know computer scientists
can can make the proper analogy here
um there's almost you know something
recursive about it i guess
um probably not using that term well
i struggle with it in my cs classes
um yeah it's backtracking
so i i think i hope that makes sense
because often we assume that certain
moves are forced
and certain lines leave a bad taste in
their mouth you're like damn you know
this doesn't work because he takes the
bishop
and so we're almost emotionally
rejecting the line rather than
approaching it
analytically and just saying all right
let me let me uncouple my emotions from
the calculation
bishop f7 is perfectly good yeah bishop
f7 is also pretty much crushing
uh it's crushing for a different reason
and he gives us a green it's crushing
for a different reason and i'll show
that after the game
but i just wanted to sort of display
this particular concept okay so here
you know there's a line to be drawn when
you're up
a queen i've worn again and again about
not
taking too much extra material and
instead focusing on important things
like development
at the same time that doesn't mean you
should refrain from taking stuff that's
literally free
so there's many ways to win this
position
um and the sort of most obvious one is
queen h5 check
and if he goes g6 we could have also
gone knight back to f7
reached back into the uh the treasure
chest and pulled out a rook but
what is the idea after g6 very typical
concept here
yeah knight takes g6 of course hg6 then
we take the rook and
just vacuum everything up the eighth
rink yeah so he goes there
we can give a check on f7
and after king c7 we have a very pretty
maiden two
very pretty made in two and again to
come back to the
one how i see this honestly it's the
fact that i have solved
tons of these made in twos made in
threes throughout my life the first one
is to swing the queen over to a5 and
deliver the check
bring the king to b7 and then the mate
itself is very pretty
does anybody see it
does anybody see the mate
nice knight v8 is made not knight d6
because the bishop defends that square
98 all right so
let's go through the game um
so e4 e5 b4 c6 we took the pawn he goes
queen a5 check
knight c3 uh again bishop d2
attacks the queen but that bishop is
super awkward and now he attacks two
pawns at once we can go knight c3 here
but then we've in effect played bishop
d2 which doesn't make much sense right
so here here here queen e6 and now
knight g5 which is
a very aggressive move now if we had
chosen the more conventional development
approach we could have done bishop d3
just supporting the pawn we could have
gone
bishop f4 getting the bishop out this
way
there's a bunch of stuff that we can do
um but
in the name of playing very aggressively
we decided on knight g5 and bishop c4
now what would have been black's best
move here
what would have been black's best move
here
yeah d5 so a lot of you guys eagle-eyed
folks spotted this during
the game and d5 is a very strong
defensive move because not only does it
open the bishop it also
uh this attacks the bishop you cannot
take on d5 because of the pin
what should white do in this position
to be honest my idea was just to drop
the bishop to drop the bishop back
and and then castle and the funny thing
is this looks very intimidating
for us like oh damn you know i missed d5
but
think of it this way once you castle the
fact that black's pawn is on d5 is a
huge blessing because it might may allow
you to take on d5 and open the e file
so even if black plays h6 right you can
just drop the knight back to f3 and
watch what happens queen c set well for
queen c7 you can take on d5
but if queen e7 i mean look at the
development advantage it's three
on zero and black is just completely a
sitting duck and
now the fact that black's pawn is on d5
is what kills him even faster
because the e5 is about to get opened
right
so what this shows is that these moves
like d5 which
make a lot of noise and they attack a
piece they exploit a pin
uh oftentimes they need to be responded
to in very quiet ways
and this also shows the really the
importance of these
general principles they exist for a
reason things like development
advantages are important
um and concept of looking for open files
all of these things
really do matter and when you look at
these top-level games you may get the
impression that we're we've all sort of
moved on collectively from chess
principles
that's definitely not the case okay
so b5 now bishop f7 check would have
been good as well
and the mechanism of this is that after
king d8 you should immediately
the alarm bells should immediately start
to ring because i'm noticing this
the knight and the queen are the king
and the queen are a night's distance
apart
and currently the bishop is parked on
that square but
uh you can send the valet and then you
can move the bishop away where can you
move it
if you're moving the bishop you might as
well take something out with you
you can take the knight and black has to
move the queen away
black is busted here if he takes the
knight f7 as a fork
and so king e7 is essentially forced and
here
what should and this is the kind of
position actually where i think
players tend to struggle because it's
not immediately clear
how about why it should continue and
that's part of the reason
it's open that's right this gm has it's
part of the reason that
um that i didn't take with the bishop
are you trying to flatter me gms
so probably so the computer's move here
is
is different from what i'm going to
suggest what did i say
just now about um swanky tiger thanks
for the sub what did i just now say
about
situations where you're unsure of what
to do or you're a little bit scared
sometimes you need to go back to the
very
simple moves can i make just a
developing move can i make a general
improving move
so just castle just castling here is
you're not going to go wrong with this
now if i can play h6 i i'm
quite sure that some of you are seeing
this and thinking well this is very bad
because
he attacks the knight if we move the
knight then he takes the bishop
but if you look a little bit more
carefully at this and if you remember
that
there's a good reason that we left the
queen on e5 we left it
uh so that we could use it as sort of a
punching bag when we need it
we go knight f3 and we attack the queen
queen moves and
remember we're up upon and the king is
ruined and uh and black is completely
busted then we can even move our bishop
away
refocus our attacking energy and then
you know attack in one of 80 80
different ways
so that would have been the mechanism
bishop f7 i think knight f7 is probably
the better move even objectively
and again if he moves his queen we just
drop the bishop back and then we take
the rook at our leisure
tetsuo's grid thank you does that make
sense i mean of course he blundered
under the queen but um at that point it
became pretty academic
any questions about this game why not
bishop b3 before knight f7 well
um here you give black a chance to
defend this pawn with knight h6
and you can no longer take on f7 it's
very important to
make that move first and trap the rook
and then
move the bishop back move order is quite
important in these in these cases
what about f4 after castle um
f4 after castle oh you mean h6 f4
instead of knight f3 allowed f4 is fine
it wouldn't solve the underlying issue
of the knight being hanging and the king
making contact with the bishop it would
actually help black move the queen away
um if that makes sense man thank you for
the raid party of 75
thank you min thank you and sorry we
didn't continue i'm finishing myself
very very soon
so a lucky morning star the point of
knight f3 is to attack the queen
right if king takes bishop then we take
the queen into the queen we have to
black has to attend to that threat
why not d4 asks sauron sp after d5
bishop b3 because
d4 reopens the bishop's diagonal and
allows knight takes f7
forking the queen and the rook and it's
the same idea
as when we took knight takes f7
okay let's play the next game
[Music]